in the united states a huge forest fire
in northern california has spread into
nevada
forcing communities to evacuate nearly
80 wildfires are burning across the u.s
west coast the largest is oregon's
bootleg fire
dw's enos pole reports on the
devastation left in its wake
the nation's biggest fire has already
destroyed an area
larger than los angeles the mega fire
is burning so hot that it essentially
generated
its own weather pattern and spread
dangerous smoke as far
as new york city the fire is moving so
fast
that many ranchers weren't able to
rescue their cattle
the small community of sprague river is
just a few miles away from the edge
of the fire summer has been living here
for more than 20 years
i know that there were there's probably
hundreds of cattle that have been lost
and there's probably hundreds of cattle
that are still out there
the jane's lost a bunch the yamsey ranch
up
joe jane they lost some the gallagher's
out here at whiskey creek ranch
which are like my family
the fire department put out signs across
the area to keep
people updated brandon and his wife
recently moved here to start a new life
as farmers this fire has been much
bigger
and seeing the clouds from it and just
seeing the containment line only be
about this big right here
for days and days and days it's it's
been a big one
many experts are convinced that the
extreme heat and drought fueling the
fires in the u.s
is caused by climate change and it's
also
why mega fires are becoming more
frequent
more than a hundred families already
have lost their homes to the flames and
thousands are evacuated it's totally
unclear
how long it'll take until
firefighters have the flames under
control
many roads are still closed the national
guard has been deployed to control
traffic in many areas only ranchers are
allowed in
to check on their cattle
according to officials the fire was
sparked
by lightning those
who have been fighting fires for years
see a pattern
i think it's possible it could be
connected to climate change yeah it's
over the past four years
it's fire every fire season seems to get
longer and
hotter more than 20
000 firefighters are battling dozens of
massive wildfires in the us right now
and the fire season has only just begun
[Music]
as we mentioned fires are also raging in
california for more i am joined now by
jason campedonia
the los angeles bureau chief of i heart
media
uh welcome to dw sir uh what's the
situation right now in california
uh it's very hot it's very dry and it's
very windy
across the state the mega fire
in northern california the dixie fire
exploded to over 140
000 acres there's also the sugar fire
which is well over a hundred thousand
acres
and the tamarack fire which started on
july
4th as a lightning strike uh has now
grown to over 50 000 acres so
it's not looking very good especially
with temperatures rising over the
weekend so the next couple of days are
going to be crucial
humidity levels are rising but it's not
enough to make any sort of impact
on the fire fight you rattle off the
names of those fires it's like a litany
of woes
how are authorities coping
uh you know right now they're throwing
everything they can at it unfortunately
the high winds in some of the areas
um we are preventing helicopters and
fixed-wing aircraft to get in there and
drop fire retardant
or drop water of any kind so they're
relying on hand crews and bulldozer
lines
and things like that and really the
firefighters are fighting exhaustion
they've been out on these fire lines
for several days now and it's really
starting to uh
make an impact you know jason i should
mention i lived in los angeles for a
decade and left back in 2016.
for at least half the time i was there i
clearly remember
scientists saying these wildfires could
be the new normal
i suspect if that's true you've already
been living
the new normal what do residents want
from the government
to be prepared for the next big blaze
which
it sounds like could happen anytime
that's an excellent point that you bring
up and i really believe that when
temperatures start to cool in january
and when the winter hits here
uh the big story is going to be the
overtime cost
that it takes to have firefighters on 24
7 365
have strike teams in place and be able
to put out spot fires as soon as
possible
i really believe that that will become
the story as the year progresses
and into next year and people just want
lives and property saved they don't care
how they don't care how much it costs
people who live in these fire prone
areas are just asking for any sort of
help
from the government local officials
state government
federal officials they don't care they
just want to make sure that their homes
are safe
and their family is safe their homes and
their families and yet
every single year when these fires hit
there's always the question
of why it is that people live in these
fire zones and given the discussion
that's happening around climate change
these days
the i have to ask the question whether
that is an issue that is
raising its head again or is there a
disbelief among folks in california that
there they're people who still put
themselves in danger
by moving into these uh areas beautiful
though they may be
so i believe it's solitude people like
living out in the middle of nowhere
because they don't have to deal with the
hustle and bustle of city life but it
really depends on who you ask because
there's two sides of the coin there's
the climate change
uh side of the coin and then there's the
forest management side of the coin
and if you get in there and you brush
the forest and you clean the forest
floor
it might prevent some of these you know
mega fires from breaking out in
areas where people live and there's also
people that are you know clearing brush
you know 50 60 yards away from their
home to keep their home protected
sometimes that works sometimes it
doesn't with the gusty winds
an ember from a wildfire from one of
these massive pine trees or sequoia
trees up in northern california
one of those embers can branch off and
be a flaming
bowling ball and hit over a mile away
which will start another fire and then
there goes those resources and then the
resources on the main fire
become extremely thin so it really
depends on who you ask and
climate change is definitely in the
conversation jason are local authorities
and residents getting uh
any kind of federal assistance here
uh at the moment uh governor gavin
newsom who is facing a recall election
is said that he is going to ask federal
authorities for
more money uh but we've already got
giant tankers which
you know can be used some of the time
but not all the time
we've got helicopters and when the bills
come from all the overtime that's when
the federal assistance will really kick
in
that is a journalist jason campedonia uh
there in california reporting for us
really
i really do appreciate your time sir and
stay safe
thank you so much